now it isn't just that you know they
want you to get used to having less the
left also wants you to feel less safe
while doing so now what do i mean well
the same week we got that new body cam
footage revealing you've all day cops to
be total incompetent cowards and the
same week a good guy with a gun saves
untold lives in indiana house judiciary
committee democrats are actually
beginning a markup on a new assault
weapons ban an attempt to further erode
our second amendment rights
now here now is ranking member of
judiciary congressman jim jordan
congressman
republicans i i feel like sometimes
they're they're kind of afraid of the
the gun issue sometimes because they
feel like oh there'll be another mass
shooting and then they're going to be on
the spot
but this is pernicious what they're
doing given
everything that we're seeing in the
public right now
no no no kidding and by the way lord
great monologue i mean you think about
it less money in your wallet less gas in
your car and now less freedom and they
are coming directly after your second
amendment liberties in an
unconstitutional way second amendment is
as clear as it gets shall not infringe
on your right to bear arms i mean it
can't get any plainer than that but
that's what they're going after i always
tell folks it says arms not musket it
says shall not infringe it doesn't say
shall not infringe unless it's an
assault weapon or whatever the democrats
want to go after that particular week so
yeah this is
i'm going to lean in and fight against
this i know you are and so many
americans know how wrong this is well i
want to show our viewers tonight how cnn
covered the news about that indiana hero
watch
police said that the gunman had a high
capacity magazine and had this bystander
not intervened when he did so quickly
more people could have been killed i
mean but are we all supposed to rely on
an armed 22 year old shouldn't have we
shouldn't have to
so
allison seemed a little upset that the
um
that's how it all went down
well just a few weeks ago when they were
passing the unconstitutional red flag
law which is going to deny people their
due process rights they were they told
us during the debate oh that good guys
with guns don't actually come in and
save things and rescue people and do the
things like this guy in indiana did when
in fact it just happened this weekend so
uh this attack though on freedom
is so wrong and think of the pattern
think of that first at first it was the
coveted lockdowns as you said in your in
your monologue then it was the the
disinformation governance board and we
haven't we have a justice department
that's still still treating moms and
dads who show up at school board
meetings to speak up for their kids
still treating them as domestic
terrorists and investigating people we
had fbi whistleblowers come forward so
this is part of a pattern of attacks on
fundamental liberties that we enjoy
under our constitution here in america
and that's why we're that's why i think
so many people are so fired up and gonna
push back on what the democrats are
doing yeah so food
fuel
personal safety and speech
right they're coming for all of it but
the voters have a chance to turn it
around congressman we need you as the
chair of the house judiciary committee
i'm going to be looking forward to next
year thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else